let me stop I say this is something that
you already ever but you gotta find the
heart in my word there's a deeper
meaning that you miss oh yes hey how's
it going guys
so now growing up for me I have been
blessed enough to have a mother who is
an amazing chef not a chef in the
traditional sense where she wears this
big all-white hand and has a big spoon
and a huge restaurant but she is to me
one of the best home cooks on earth
hands down and obviously there's a clear
bias because I'm a son but what can I
say
best eye on earth so of course when I
run up some down time to go back home
one of the biggest things I look forward
to is eating her home-cooked meals now I
know that there's a few of you out there
they can't relate to this because just
because you have parents doesn't mean
that they cook well and all I can say
that that is just uh [ __ ] sucks but
let's go in and talk about this for a
second so for me growing up food was
never just to form a sustenance you know
it always went beyond that I honestly
believe that for me growing up if I
didn't share all the meals that I shared
with them I don't think I would be
anywhere near as close to them as I am
now sharing these meals at the dinner
table was a way for us to acknowledge
each other and also show our love and
affection without having to use words my
mom for a lot of you guys out there
whose mothers cook as well you guys know
that when they use their hands to cook
the food that they make for us to eat
they do it with all their heart and soul
so when we take that first huge bite of
our food and we have that stupidly happy
grin on our face that's the form of love
and affection that our moms want to see
and yeah again and we live in a very
fast-paced society which is a big reason
to why most of us go out to eat anyways
we kind of think of cooking a sort of a
nuisance and a chore we have to go out
of our way to go to the grocery store
buy these ingredients make a huge mess
in the kitchen just for one hot meal but
you see a lot of you guys are forgetting
the whole point of making a home-cooked
meal and sitting around a table and
sharing that experience with your family
has nothing to do with convenience it's
really about the connection that you
make when you sit at a table and you
partake in something that somebody
created to nourish your body and it's
sad that convenience is the one thing
that's tearing us away from these things
that I honestly believe is a
fundamentally important part of being a
human being there's this concept of us
instead of me and for me food was the
thing that bridged that gap you know for
a lot of you out there that have a
mother father a parent or even a grandpa
that takes the time to make these hot
meals for you think about it for a
second what it means to them do you
realize that there was a certain point
in your life you couldn't wait to eat
what your mom had to make for you there
was a point in your life where your mom
held you in her arms and for you
that woman was all that you had she was
your world and you know fast forward to
now when you're a team there are times
when you look at your parents as if when
they walk into your room you wish they
never existed even when you grow up and
you move past that and your relationship
is okay there's a certain point in your
parents life where they realize that you
don't need them like you used to and for
them that hits them like a dagger those
meals that you take for granted with
your family those are things that are
finite you know for me I try not to
think or even talk about these things
because when I do it brings me down but
at the same time if I don't do this it
doesn't put things in perspective for me
I need this so the next time you're
about to go out and you know that
someone you love cooked you a hot meal
and you want to tell them that you're
gonna go out to eat instead don't think
about the food that you're about to eat
think about the heart and the hands that
make them
Oh
do